beaucoup de questions encore sans
réponse après le décès d'une habitante
de Fondettes dans la nuit du 25 au 26
décembre se plaignant de difficultés à
respirer cette sexagénaire s'est
présentée avec son mari aux urgences de
la clinique de l'Alliance à
Saint-Cyr-sur-Loire elle n'aurait pas
été prise en charge faute d'avoir appelé
le 15 au préalable comme recommandé par
l'agence régionale de santé elle est
décédée peu de temps après d'une crise
cardiaque à son domicile en attendant
les secours pour l'instant la famille de
la victime n'a pas déposé plainte une
enquête judiciaire a été ouverte par le
parquet pour déterminer si le décès
pouvait résulter d'une infraction pénale
il faut reconstituer ce qui s'est dit
parce que lorsque cette personne s'est
présentée à l'accueil des urgences il
faut savoir comment elle a été reçue si
elle a été reçue par une personne qui
avait une capacité de décision est-ce
que cette personne avait aussi une
capacité de diagnostic puisque à
l'évidence il y avait une détresse
respiratoire
cette détresse à toi était en lien avec
des problèmes cardiaques majeurs est-ce
qu'il était possible de contrôler cela
ou est-ce qu'il était impossible compte
tenu de l'état de tension des urgences
d'effectuer le moindre contrôle y a-t-il
une assistance à personne en danger si
les auditions convergent vers cette
hypothèse le parquet pourrait initier
des procédures devant un tribunal
correctionnel voir saisir un juge
d'instruction mais tout éventuel faute
sera appréciée au regard des
circonstances bien entendu le parquet
devra tenir compte de circonstances
exceptionnelles c'est à dire qu'à
l'évidence il y avait un système
d'urgence qui était totalement saturé en
Indre-et-Loire et et la question à se
poser des de savoir si
on est tenu à l'impossible parce que les
services d'urgence sont tellement
surbookés qu'à un moment donné il risque
d'y avoir des difficultés comme celles
qui a existé ce 26 décembre
c'est donc au terme de cette enquête que
le procureur décidera de la classer sans
suite ou bien d'engager des poursuites
pénales